All
Morning.
Good. I'm good. Ready to go? All right.
Good morning everybody. Oh, hey,
you can, you can come shake my hand.
That's cool. Come on, let's do it. Let's do it. That's good.
We got it. Good morning. All right,
you can continue those conversations after we're done today.
Hope you met somebody new and uh, just feel welcome.
If you are new to our church,
we're grateful that you would be here.
We would like to get to know you if we can At some point,
whenever you feel comfortable enough to do that,
you can head to the new area out there
or the QR code in front of you.
We just wanna help you connect to our church, find a place
that you can call home
and really find a community
of people that you can call family.
And so that's what we wanna help you do.
Hopefully we can at some point soon for you.
But as you can tell though, today is something special.
We're you celebrating something unique where uh,
it's the end of our series through this summer we've called
realigned and it's been in Romans chapter 12.
As we walk that road, we just have seen God
do an amazing work.
And we've used this illustration the whole time,
this plumb line that we've said Jesus
sets the perfect standard for us.
So from the top down measured that he is, he is showing us
as Romans 12 describes
what the perfect life would look like,
what a transformed life in Christ would look like as
we are transformed by him.
Now, it's been challenging for us every week as we've seen
God push us with his word in Romans 12, all
of these things showing us
how far from this standard we actually are, if we're honest,
plus how we are so prone to want to measure ourselves off
of some other standard, right?
The world's standard or somebody else around us
and we say, man, look, I'm not that far off.
If we're measuring off of that, that's the problem.
We have to flip it around
and measure off of the perfect standard of Christ.
And, and so today what we're gonna see is how
that process of realignment actually occurs.
And we've seen Romans 12 show us what we should be.
Christ is the perfect standard, but how does it happen day
after day for God to pull us back to that standard
to realign us to his image?
Now some of you might have already turned
to Romans chapter 12 since we have every Sunday this summer.
That's okay. We'll see it a little bit,
but we actually need for some more focus on this turn
to second Corinthians chapter three.
So if you're at Romans 12,
you can just turn right a little bit, you'll get
to first Corinthians
and then second Corinthians chapter three,
that's the big number three.
And we're gonna be in two verses in that verses 17 and 18.
And these will show us again
what this focus on transformation means and
and what, how it happens really
as we get into this idea of christlikeness.
So two Corinthians chapter three verses 17 and 18.
And then we'll come back and
and dig through it a little bit.
Now, the Lord is the Spirit
and where the spirit of the Lord is, there is freedom.
And we all, with unveiled face beholding the glory
of the Lord are being transformed into the same image from
one degree of glory to another.
For this comes from the Lord who is the Spirit.
Lord, as we come to your word in this moment, we do pray
that, that we would see this transformation begin
for some people today, that they would be awakened
by your spirit to know and believe,
but for all of us, that we would be taken one step,
one degree further in this transformation process
and then tomorrow and the next day.
And that your spirit, Lord, your spirit in us,
would change us to
where we're different than we were before.
Help us God. We need you to do that.
We can't do that ourselves. This has gotta be your work.
So we give you glory for it
and ask you to do it in Jesus' name.
Amen. So the context
of this passage is similar
to the context we were at in Romans 12,
where the apostle Paul is writing to this local church
and he's explaining the gospel why they need salvation and
and what they do about it, but then also
what it does in their lives.
And so he's both before salvation, why and after and how.
And so he's talking the same kind of way,
but here he uses Moses from the Old Testament
as a case study.
And so he kind of compares the old covenant
with a new covenant
and he explained that this new covenant,
that the oh Moses was under the old covenant,
that the new covenant we are under
actually removes the veil from our hearts so
that we can now understand the Lord, understand his word,
and we can actually in a sense, see his glory
that Moses had to be really careful with.
We can see in a different way by faith we can see God.
And so that's the context of this difference back and forth.
We'll come back to that a little bit more throughout.
But you also saw the Spirit mentioned here
a couple times specifically that the Lord is the spirit
and the spirit gives freedom.
Now this is all referring to the Holy Spirit,
the third person of the Trinity, uh, the three in one God
that we worship different than other religions,
that it's Father Son Spirit co-equal, uh,
but distinct three persons in one essence
that's really hard to understand.
But the Trinity is what we're talking about
specifically the Holy Spirit's role in salvation
is first to secure and seal
and guarantee our eternal inheritance like a down payment
on something you'll get later.
The Holy Spirit is God with us.
So we are assured of God being with us
and us being with God forever down payment
of something coming.
That's part of the Holy Spirit's role is
to seal our salvation.
But also Galatians four, six says, the Holy Spirit fills us
whenever we are adopted into God's family.
So not only seals us, surrounds us,
but also fills us who believe it.
That that means listen, if you're a Christian,
if you've said Jesus, you are my Lord
and Savior, I believe that means the Holy Spirit,
God's spirit, third person,
the trinity has filled your soul, filled you up.
I know it's hard to understand because it's
a spiritual thing.
God himself lives within you
and all that God is has is flowing in you and through you.
And second Corinthians three says, he is the mechanism
for our sanctification.
Uh, sanctification is a big word
that means growth in christlikeness,
that you become more like Jesus.
You're growing in holiness. That's what that means.
So the Holy Spirit planted in you is how you are sanctified.
This is not a new concept.
We saw this back at the beginning of Romans 12,
just a few months ago when we started the series.
Listen to verses one and two again. Remember this?
He said, I appeal to you,
therefore brothers, by the mercies of God
to present your bodies as a living sacrifice, holy
and acceptable to God, which is your spiritual worship.
But then listen to this. Do not be conformed to the world,
but be transformed by the renewal of your mind.
That by testing may discern what is the will of God,
what is good and acceptable and perfect.
So remember the structure of this whole series.
We jumped in at Romans 12.
We had to kind of talk about Romans one through 11.
First Romans one through 11 is Paul explaining
why you need to be saved.
Like this is a problem sin, you can't fix it.
You can't do anything about it. God did everything for it.
You believe in God, he redeems you, he changes you,
makes you new, all of those things.
That's Romans one through 11 and then Romans 12,
therefore that first word, therefore
because of what God has done, all
of his mercy and grace to you.
Therefore, Romans 12 begins to talk about
what the new life looks like, the new life he's purchased
for you and given you, made you born again.
Here's now 12 through 16 what it actually looks like
in the Holy Spirit's power to transform you
because he's given this to you.
You now have the opportunity to live out
what he's called you to.
He changes you into that.
That leads us right back to Second Corinthians three,
which shows us how God's spirit actually does that.
So we're gonna pick out three simple points from these
couple verses of how the Holy Spirit does this.
First, it's that the Holy Spirit gives freedom
for transformation.
The first thing we see in these passages,
the Holy Spirit gives freedom for the transformation
that he says here in the text.
And it's pretty obvious, we saw it in verse 17,
where the spirit of the Lord is there is freedom,
like so there's, it's a guarantee.
The spirit of the Lord is there.
There's freedom there at that location.
Wherever the spirit of Lord is, there is freedom.
And then he talks about transformation after that.
Now here's the thing for us in America,
when we hear the word freedom, we tend to think of man,
that means I can do whatever I want, right?
We've got this, this document that says we can have freedom
of religion, freedom of press, freedom
to say what we need to say.
All of those things we, we are free to do
what we want to do.
But the problem with that is
that's not the way the Bible talks
about freedom in this context.
This is not freedom from God's demands.
This is freedom to become
all he's created you to be.
So here, here's the picture of this.
You go back to Romans 12, two,
we are freed from the conformity to this world.
We don't have to be conformed to the world anymore.
That's the sin nature. That's what we had to do.
We don't have to be that anymore.
We're freed from that to be transformed
by the work of God in our lives.
That's the freedom. The freedom we have is that we are dead
to sin and we're alive to God.
Now that we couldn't not sin, we had to do that.
Now we can do what God's called.
We can live a different life.
That's the freedom, not freedom to do whatever we want.
The veil has been lifted.
That spiritual blindness that we had has been gone.
The bondage of self-centered living has been shattered.
We don't have to live like that anymore.
We can live a new life.
That's the freedom that he's talking about here,
where the spirit of the Lord is there is freedom.
Now, you might be sitting there saying, well,
I feel like I'm free right now.
Maybe you're not a believer and you're like,
oh, I've been, I can do whatever I want.
I'm free. Now, we've said this nearly every week.
The Bible talks about us in such a way that every one
of us are born slaves to sin,
that we can do nothing but that.
And the whole orientation of our lives from birth is self,
self, self, self.
Get what I want, get what I want, do something kind
so I can get something out of it.
Like all of that is self.
It's the way all of all of us are oriented from birth
because of the sin nature.
And so looking at something like Romans 12,
what we've done all summer, looking at that,
you look at the self-sacrificial lifestyle
and there is no way we could do that on our own
little hints here and there.
There's no way we could live out Romans 12 just by virtue
of us pulling up our bootstraps and going for it.
We can do this. No, there's no way.
'cause our whole heart is self.
Yet when the spirit awakens our hearts
frees us from the chains of self-centered living.
Then we are able dead to sin alive to God.
We are able to live a life of joyful surrender
to the Lord now that we couldn't do before.
We actually were rebelling and opposed to God in our sin.
And now we're free to live a life of joyful surrender.
The veil's been lifted, we can see God's glory in a way
and that should compel us to live a life then
that honors that glory.
We'll talk a lot more about that later.
And so lemme just talk to you if you are a believer
for a second, lemme just say this very clearly.
If you've confessed Christ as your Lord and Savior
and the Holy Spirit and dwells within you as a result of
that belief, if right now you feel like you are trapped in a
sin and you feel like there's no way out,
there's nothing you can do to
fix this, you just have to sin.
It's where you were born this way, right? And I just can't.
I can't not sin. If you are a believer,
you are wrong in believing that
if where the spirit of the Lord is, there's freedom
and you feel like you're trapped
by a sin believer, you're wrong.
There's freedom for those who are in Christ.
It's a failure to, if you stay in there, it's a failure
to understand the explosive power of the gospel.
That second Corinthians five says, if you are in Christ,
you are a new creation.
The old has gone. The new has come.
Now the old still tries to hang on and tries to come back,
but the old is dead.
It has no more power over you.
The new has come again, you're not perfect right away.
You still have to battle stuff to work and fight.
We'll see that again in a moment.
But you have been freed to live a different life than
what you had before You.
You believed like you're, you're free now
to not have to live that life anymore.
You're free to live a new life.
Then again, some of you can't remember
'cause you were like six when you came to faith.
The still right before you were six,
you didn't like your brother
very much, and so you heard him, right?
Well, now you don't have to do that anymore,
even when you don't like him very much
or you came to faith as an adult
and you see this radical transformation of
what you were doing.
God changed new life completely born
again and everything's different.
You can see that very clearly. Either way.
Either way, it's a new life.
The old has gone, the new has come.
And that means you can live differently.
Maybe think about it this way, here's an illustration.
Imagine you were wrapped up in chains.
You're enslaved to something,
yet someone you didn't know couldn't have access to,
walked up, purchased your freedom, redeemed you
and cut those chains.
Man, how joy filled would you be?
Be overwhelmed or excited about that.
But what if you just sat there
still wrapped up in the chains?
You can see that they're cut.
You can see that they're broken,
yet you just still sit there wrapped up in the chains.
They have no more power over you.
But there you sit pretty silly, right?
Yet that's what you and I do every single day.
The the freedom, the where the spirit of the Lord is.
There is freedom. If the spirit of the Lord dwells in you,
believer there's freedom, the chains have been broken,
you don't have to sit there wrapped up in the chains
anymore, that once held you enslaved to sin.
You are not enslaved any more.
You can walk in the transformation
that God has purchased for you.
It's possible. But as I said
before, that growth
and change will not most likely be instantaneous.
That's the second point.
Today, the Holy Spirit produces
progressive transformation.
Most likely won't be instantaneous.
But what the Holy Spirit does as he brings freedom
also produces progressive transformation in your life.
This goes back to two Corinthians three.
Look again at verse 18. See what it says.
It's very clear We all
with unveiled face, behold the glory of the Lord
are being transformed into the same image from one degree
of glory to another.
Now, I wanna work through that verse just piece by piece
because I, it has so much to teach us about this idea
of transformation.
And what I want you to see first is the goal.
What's the goal of this transformation?
It's that we, each of us who are believers, that we
reflect eventually perfectly reflect the image
of the glory of God.
Now, what even is that?
What's the image of the glory of God?
Well, Colossians one 15, Jesus is the perfect image of God.
And so the glory of God revealed to us is Jesus
glory come, the glory's been revealed.
It's Jesus God the Son taking on flesh.
That is the image that we will eventually reflect,
that God's glory shows up.
It's the same thing. Romans 8 29 says, those whom God
for knew he also predestined to be conformed to the image
of his son.
That is the believer's destiny
to be conformed to the image of his son.
That's why we've used this as the illustration
for this whole realigned series.
He's the standard. What God is doing in us is
realigning us, conforming us to the image of his son.
Romans 12 shows us what that looks like day to day.
That if Jesus was living your life,
that's what it would look like.
It's perfect. That's what he is bringing us to as well.
But notice the next words there in verse 18.
It says, we are being transformed
first since we're about to get back to school, right?
Grammar lesson that's passive.
We are being transformed. This is God's work.
That is even what the verse said.
This comes from the Lord who is the spirit.
This is God's work in us.
Now we offer ourselves living sacrifices,
but God is the one who does the transforming in our souls.
So it's God's work.
We are being transformed,
but also it's a continuous process.
It's an ongoing transformation.
It says we are being transformed.
Being is an ongoing word. It's not a one time event.
You don't come to Christ.
I know it's maybe discouraging to some of you,
but like you come to Christ, you at camp
or at a church service or at home with your mom like,
and you, you came to Christ and you thought everything would
be perfect and it wasn't.
You still struggled with the same stuff
yesterday, tomorrow, every day, right?
Like you still like, I thought
this would be over with by now.
No, it's not an immediate instantaneous transformation.
It's a continual work of grace.
One of my favorite verses Philippians one, six, he who began
a good work in you will bring it to completion at the day
of Jesus Christ, right?
That's a process. He started
something, he's gonna finish that.
Well, there's a process to get there.
That's what he's doing in you.
It's what he's doing in us day after day.
So it's progressive. It's a process.
But there's also another phrase.
It says, one degree of glory to another.
That's the steps. It's another idea of process of growth.
It's progressive. It's even slow, but it's one degree.
One degree, one degree. It's one step at a time.
It's like if you're gonna refine gold,
if you're gonna purify gold,
it's not perfectly refine when it comes outta the ground.
You have to put it in a furnace.
You have to heat it up one degree
after one degree, one degree more, one degree more.
The more you do, the more dross comes off,
the more the bad stuff comes out.
One degree more, more bad stuff comes out.
That's what he's talking about.
He's saying, you're the gold.
You're being refined one degree of glory to the next
over and over and over again,
refined into the image
of Christ as you go through your life.
But then notice there's one more piece of this.
How this transformation happens is by
beholding the glory of the Lord.
You see that beholding the glory of the Lord is
how it happens.
Now, if you know your Old Testament, you know
that that was something that they were afraid of
because they would die, right?
Isaiah six, he, he gets a vision of the glory of God
and he's like, I'm gonna die.
Woe is me. I'm on my face. I'm about getting me outta here.
That kind of thing. So what does this mean?
Behold the glory of the Lord.
We should be scared of that, right?
Like if we saw the glory of God, we would die.
So what's he saying?
Well, how we see the glory of God today
since we don't see the vision of God,
we're not seeing Jesus walk around all the time.
So what is the, the glory of God for us? What do we see it?
How do we behold the glory of the Lord today?
Well, first and foremost, it's through God's word.
It is through God's word.
What you hold in your hand is God's revelation
of himself to his people, right?
This is, he's told us what he's like.
He's told us who he is. He told us his character.
He's told us his nature.
He said, this is revealing the glory of the Lord.
This is how you, you see it,
and this is the primary mechanism the spirit uses
to shape your life, right?
Ephesians six calls it the sword of the Spirit.
Well, I love how Hebrews four plays off of that.
Verse 12 says, the word of God is living
and active, sharper than any two-edged sword, piercing
to the division of soul and of spirit, joints
and marrow, discerning the thoughts
and intentions of the heart.
Here's what happens for me sometimes,
maybe this happens for you.
You can go through life. You kinda look at your day
and you think, man, I'm doing pretty good.
I'm not cussing anybody out. I'm not lying.
I'm not stealing stuff like I I didn't hurt anybody today.
I'm, I'm doing pretty good.
Well, the problem is what the Bible does is, is it
pierces to notice what it said, the thoughts
and intentions of the heart.
And that's when it starts to get painful, right?
It's like you can live all the actions out,
you can do all the right things, you can do everything
right, but then it reveals the fact
that you've been actually doing those things,
selfishly doing those things to manipulate somebody else.
And that's where it starts to get into the fact
that you are not as holy.
I am not as holy as I thought I was.
The sword has cut deep into my soul, revealing,
exposing where I am actually not
as close to aligned as I thought I was.
That's the spirit working in your life through the word.
And so hear me, if you are not in
God's word for yourself,
like if you're not digging into it regularly, daily, moment
by moment, like just however you can getting into it
to allow you to see behold the glory of the Lord,
and allow the spirit to change you through that, listen,
you're not going to change as much as you hope you would.
This is how he does it. First
and foremost, he uses this.
Now, you come on Sundays in here
and we do our best to exalt the glory of God
and we try to hope you, you see the glory of God through
what we do here, but it will not be enough compared
to the daily pull of the world and of your own flesh.
You've got to fight with the armor of God, the sword
of the spirit that he has given us to say, behold the glory
of the Lord be changed every day.
So that's the first way. But here's what else he uses.
He uses other people.
He uses other people to refine us
into his image.
We saw that in Romans 12, right?
We saw that, that this, this serving others
who aren't like you, it reveals God's
glory in, in unique ways.
And we a couple ways. First with brothers
and sisters in the church, like as you love them genuinely,
as you honor them, as you pray for them,
you see God more clearly.
You reveal God back
and forth that you, that man, I've,
I've seen it in a hospital room where you're struggling
to see the glory of God and somebody encourages you,
points you to them point, points you to the glory of God
that you never would've seen it.
And you need encouragement. You need a reminder.
You see the glory of God through each other.
There's also another way.
You've heard us talk a couple times today already about, um,
the need in kids' ministry.
And it will be, hear me, it will be a sacrifice.
It will be challenging.
Your con, your comfort, maybe a little,
your convenience on Sundays for you to step into
that world and serve.
But when you look at Romans 12, three through eight, right
after, I'm gonna offer myself as living sacrifice,
verses three through eight are about serving the church.
And they're the biggest chunk of
that whole section in chapter 12.
And you know what happens, like when you step into serving,
especially in a way like that, that God's blessed us
with all these new families coming
and we don't have enough people to, to manage the chaos
of having many, many rooms that we didn't plan for, right?
We just see that happening.
God's bringing more great problem.
But when you step into a world like that
and you serve, yeah, it'll impact those kids.
You heard Everly talk about that. But it changes
you more than anybody else.
It, it affects your heart. It gives you humble sacrifice.
It also helps you grow in the way that you have
to teach something to somebody else.
Man, you better know it, right?
That all of that, that's part of the process of serving.
That's how God uses other people to reveal his glory to us.
We can see it as we serve other people. He shows up to us.
Then think about those outside the church,
even enemies when you are loving them, we behold more
of God's character as we love them.
Like this is what God did with us
and we're convicted when we don't do it.
Well. This is God's loving of us as enemies.
I can love my enemy as well.
God uses other people to reveal his glory to us.
And so over the course of your life, as you walk
through the entirety of your life, as you behold the glory
of the Lord, in all of these ways
and many other ways, you should be able to see
progressive growth over time.
Again, not immediate. It may look a little bit like this
as you go, but over time it will progressively show up.
Here's the temptation though,
that I face in my life, and you probably do as well.
When we talk about growth, it is really tempting to start
to compare yourself with other people and their growth.
It's really tempting to say, man, that guy, he's
so far ahead of me, and it can get discouraging to me.
It can also get prideful as you start to compare yourself.
Man, why didn't they figure this out?
I'm this far along, and that's wrong too.
But more likely the temptation is for you
to compare yourself to somebody who's further down the road
and you get discouraged by that.
Hear me? Don't do that.
You can learn from people who are further along,
but don't get discouraged by people who are further along.
Because remember this illustration,
I used it earlier in the series,
like when you see an oak tree, how did that thing start?
Art? It was some absent-minded squirrel carrying an acorn,
dug it hole, buried it, forgot where it was,
and what did God do?
Brought the rain began to germinate, that
roots started to grow down.
Uh, a little stem started to pop up above the ground.
Tiny little branches coming off buds of leaves.
So tender on the branches.
Now you look at that and like, that's not much.
We mow over those things all the time, right?
But that's an oak tree, isn't it?
That's, that's an oak tree.
It may be small, but that's an oak tree.
It may not be producing a lot of fruit yet,
but that is an oak tree.
It may not be 30 tons like that other one was,
but it's an oak tree.
That's what the spirit does in you friend.
Listen, what may be small.
Now, he intends to grow that into a powerful image
reflecting his glory
as you offer yourself as a living sacrifice, as you
John 15 talks about, as you abide in him, he begins
to produce those buds of fruit in your life
that eventually feed others and plant new trees.
I love the way one preacher put this.
It's a little bit of a long quote,
but listen, as a follower of Jesus,
the spirit of God is in you.
He's not just rushing upon you and then leaving you.
He actually has rushed upon you
and dwells in you now so
that you might be turned into a totally different person
and be conformed, transformed into the image
of Jesus more today.
That's the spirit's desire in your life today
to transform you more and more
and more into the image of Jesus
more tomorrow at this time than you are right now at this
time, looking more like Jesus, thinking more like Jesus,
loving more like Jesus, speaking more like Jesus.
See, when God plants an acorn, he means an oak tree.
He means for that to be an oak.
That's what he's doing in you believer.
That's what He's doing in me.
It doesn't look like that yet, but it's on the way
and he's working it out.
He's doing it in your life as you submit to him.
And you know why he does it that way.
You know why he's transforming you,
because that brings him so much more glory.
Like that's what this piece,
the Holy Spirit's transformation,
what it does is it reflects God's glory.
Like it shows him off to the world.
When you are progressively changed into the image of Christ,
it shows God off to the world.
And notice what verse 18 said, we behold the glory
of God, we see it.
But then verse 18 says,
we're being transformed into the same image from one degree
of glory to another.
Like this is the ultimate purpose
of your transformation in life.
God's glory being displayed through transformed lives,
empowered by His spirit.
That's what he designed for us.
Like when we live as these kind of Romans 12 Christians,
and we offer our bodies of living sacrifices,
we serve using our gifts.
We are looking to overcome evil with good.
We're loving even our enemies,
we're loving our brothers, all of that.
When we do that, Romans 12, we become mirrors
reflecting God's glory to the world.
And so we're changed by God's spirit. Absolutely we are.
But that's not merely for our benefit, not so you can walk
around and say how powerful of a Christian you are.
He transforms us so that God's own glory shines
through ordinary believers like us living extraordinary
lives, empowered by the spirit of God.
Man, that shows him off.
Now, I mentioned Moses earlier, it's the context
of two Corinthians three in,
in Israel's exodus from slavery in Egypt.
There's an interesting part of Moses' life
that might often get overlooked.
See, Moses went up to the mountain, Mount Sinai to meet
with God twice.
The second time when he came back down from the mountain,
after seeing the glory of God,
he comes down from the mountain
and his face is shining with the glory of God.
And he gets down to the camp and everybody is terrified
because they know the glory
of God could strike them down at any point
that they could die because of it.
And so they're like, Hey, Moses, no, no, no.
You need to put something over that.
And so he veiled his face So they wouldn't see it.
Do you remember what second Corinthians three talked about
For us, for those
of us who've been made alive by the Spirit,
who've seen God's glory in the gospel,
that need for a veil has been taken away.
Because here's the difference.
The glory that we behold is a new covenant.
Moses was on the old covenant. We're under new covenant.
That will not fade
and that will transform us into the same degree
of glory from one degree to the next.
That's the difference today,
because of that new covenant of God's grace
through Jesus' life, death,
and resurrection, this is the unveiled face
that we shine brightly.
We don't have to veil it anymore
because it's good news
that people don't need to be afraid of it.
They need to see it and say, man, I want some of that.
That's the glory of God shining through the grace
of God in our lives.
Our lives are intended to reflect God's glory
to this dark world.
That's the reason God did this.
That's the reason God created you.
Isaiah 43 says, that's the reason the Spirit recreated you.
Ephesians two says, this is so you and I would behold him
and walk in the spirit's transformation in our lives so
that people will see our good works
and glorify our Father who is in heaven.
It's why he designed you. It's why he recreated you.
So let's pray. Now, let's, let's ask,
let's all ask the Lord, if you would just bow your head
with me right now and just say, God,
and maybe, maybe this is the first time you've ever done
this, but You would just say to God,
listen, Lord, I I don't understand all of it.
God, I don't know where all of this will end as far as
how it's gonna play out day by day,
but I do know where it will end.
I know it will end Jesus with you,
making me perfectly like you when you return
and, and here's the the part maybe you've never prayed to.
Just maybe open your hands.
And just to say to God, I'm willing to do whatever it takes.
I'm willing to, to experience whatever
you want me to experience.
I'm willing to walk through whatever you want me to walk
through so that you get more glory
through my life as you change me into your image.
Like that's a scary prayer.
I know, but that's
what God wants to do in you.
It's why he designs you.
It's why he re redesigns you in the spirit.
And there's hope in this because you don't deserve it.
I don't deserve it. Yet, he graciously gave forgiveness
as far off from the alignment
that I am hegra granted me Grace,
granted you grace by the blood of Jesus shed for you.
So what else response should we give? But he's worthy.
So I'll just invite you to submit to him, to offer yourself
as a living sacrifice.
Holy, already holy
and pleasing to God as your spiritual act of worship.
To then say, God, I don't want to conform to the world.
I wanna be transformed by you. Make me different.
Make me different. That a year from now we look back
and see how much you have done.
As I've rejoiced in your gospel, glory,
I've studied your word.
I've been around believers, I've served the church.
I've cared for my neighbors. I've loved my enemies.
God I've, I've seen you grow me in all those things.
Not where I need to be yet, but praise God.
I'm not where I was. Just submit to
that, Lord, help us.
This is your work. We need you to do it.
So for your glory, we pray in Jesus' name, amen.
If you're able, let's stand together
and respond that he is the one who does this
and submit to that.